does is that where does Shaq live in
Texas yeah oh he actually got to have
some Dallas I heard Shaq's got a [__]
crab out there yeah he'd be out there so
because he he was from Texas right I
don't think so from Texas yeah he's from
Texas
he went to school at LSU but I know he
like his dad was in the military step
dad oh yeah he is from Texas yeah a lot
of people hey there's some Texas goats
out here
I didn't know that
I think my uncle got b-bombed in
Clarksville wait what happened my uncle
he played basketball with him against
him and he lost in the playoffs damn or
was that the championship one of them
you guys even watch baseball like the
Rangers are they even a thing in your
life you know I've never been to a
baseball like ever game until I just
went into the first pitch at the Rangers
game how was it I didn't see it was it
like a a respectable pitch did you hit
the dirt oh yeah I threw like the it was
like a 30 mile per hour curve ball but
it wasn't nice remember the 50 Cent
pitch was rough yeah
you did what you're supposed to do
I just didn't understand what the [__]
was going on baseball's a terrible sport
yeah I don't go Rangers go Rangers I
mean they played Texas I just watch
football and basketball I like the like
the like the hockey [__] again like I'm
sure do you guys like the Dallas Stars
no but they play Texas so go Stars
I was gonna say you didn't you said play
Texas you didn't say Dallas I was gonna
say you're a [__] traitor because
you're a [__] Texas
no they play Texas they play the song so
oh they play your song No Texas is going
crazy you're right there has there's no
way you walk into an arena in the state
of Texas and they're not playing that
song so that's why every team we sang
when I heard that song in my head I just
pictured The Source magazine Don't Mess
with Texas cover for Mike my childhood
that's all just playing out in person
you remember that cover uh you said from
your childhood I'm only 25. it was like
Jay Prince Bun B Mike Jones [__]
everybody was on this cover and I like
pulled out and it was like during that
like real I guess the last time like
places was was lit man so like you don't
know it was a ton were you listening to
like uh the thing about Dallas people
don't understand is like a lot of like
older Dallas [__] like I think a dero
you know I think of like some of the
more fun [__] uh yeah my Dougie that's
definitely where Dallas is based off of
right it's more like
um I feel like for you like did you grow
up listening to any of that like more
the the dance dancing I used to be a
dancer [__] everybody was if you
say you wasn't dancing he was from
Dallas you're lying so you could learn
you got some moves you got some tick
tocks in you
Friday night I'm [__] coming pause
hey yo
I've been I've been getting away with
some egregious ones lately man I'm sorry
you're performing yeah uh when is listen
you're about to Freestyle
so you guys are gonna see how crazy he
is as artists but what do you got going
on bro
uh just a bunch of singles right now
yeah just dropping a whole bunch of
singles you guys are like [__] you
guys really came into [__] together
you guys went to high school together
you guys [__] ran up the shipping War
now he actually the one who he's been
rapping with nine nine could you learn a
lot from him yeah for sure that's why I
keep him with me because it's like I
still it's still [__] that I don't know
like when it comes to writing and
smoking he's just I just got the voice
then there your voice is special I got
the voice no you could rap bro yeah I
mean I just got something to talk it's
not hard to well you got something yeah
some really bad rappers yeah yeah I just
like I saw Playboy Guardian concert at
rolling loud and I just was really lost
I was like uh I just really confused
and I I respect his team and I respect
him and I respect their movement but
he's the one artist
because I get most of this [__] it might
not be for me but like you know I'd get
a little Oozy like I'm like yeah this
shit's hard I get it look
playway card is one guy
and I don't know what the [__] going
on I'm gonna name one more Jaleel
well he'd just be doing backflips
I ain't heard one of his songs I just
know that [__] is ripped bro
yeah man I know Jaleel I should check
his music out because I don't want to
speak about his music without having to
listen to it
I just know he is
he's got a career in like you know
wrestling wrestling oh my God for sure
he could be a wrestler he already got a
Jaleel yeah yeah I understand it
backflips and just he's just [__]
like I'm like bruh he actually do like
wrestling stunts on his shows I saw you
know I've seen a lot of artists starting
to like do these fake [__] wrestling
moves on fans which is crazy because if
they are real fans it's dangerous as
[__] but there's no way they're real
fans yeah [__] are doing RKOs
and the tables in the middle of their
show and they're like it was a fan I'm
like no it wasn't you're not just RKO
and I'm a random stranger into a table
hell no that's a [__] lawsuit yeah
for sure have you ever this is a wild
question it should have an obvious no to
it but have you ever ground surfed
yeah
nope one of these days I'm gonna get my
big ass up there they don't care you bro
they better but what you don't do is I
gotta wait till I'm like Beyonce or
Drake levels where I got like each dive
though my mama I gotta like I'm gonna
get on my knees and just lay so what you
do is pause
I crash a lot of my life you get into
the crowd and you find the biggest
[__]
right and then you just tap their
shoulder and you say and then they'll
get you up and then you start tapping
the people in front so then they'll tap
and then this is at Rock shows for the
most part or like a Tech N9ne concert
and then and then they'll then usually
everyone's in communication that was
dangerous is when you just like out of
nowhere like yeah then you jump and your
fans aren't expecting you to do that one
you might die and two you might kill
someone
certain stages where I can't get down
bro go
is lit
just don't have money still trying to
[__] rob you you gotta you gotta wait
till we you gotta wait till we like like
super mega stuff no for sure I feel like
raw wave could crowd surf right now
someone would die though
not if everybody's on the same page
everyone has to be on the same page you
gotta say hey hey
but yeah
that's why I said it's more of a you
gotta like sit down and just lay back
and just live yes you gotta do this you
gotta do a slow yeah cause if he jumped
they're gonna do like but to get him
back on stage
I don't know if you saw Broadway's
broken a whole stage before I don't know
if you saw that and I'm gonna take up
for him because that's actually my
favorite artist
that wasn't his fault that was all those
people that were on stage with him also
shout out to Rod Wade one of my favorite
artists he's from St Petersburg Florida
which I used to live He's a sweet guy
too man yeah I like you know what I like
about Rod wave he's so anti-industry
yeah like he don't give a [__] about
being your friend he ain't trying to
kick it with rappers he's doing none of
the weirdo [__] he's just making records
I'm trying to kick you with your ride
listen listen bro I [__] with you I
don't even got to do no songs but I just
[__] with you and yeah we need to tell
you no I love Rod he and he's like he
can make country he can make pop music I
mean he's just such an amazing
songwriter that'll happen for you man I
mean it's gonna happen uh we was just at
uh G5 of Miami great place he was there
great chicken wings and the wild it was
they said he was there I didn't see him
that happened DJ said old Broadway or
something something what if the DJ
accidentally thought you were Rod wave
that would be [__] up because I get
that all the time I get this [__] out
walked in and the guys are like yo shout
out to Rod wave in the building and you
you're like what if that's what the [__]
he was talking about and then you're
like oh dear song you're like yo that's
dope Rod waves here but DJ thought you
were wrong with me bro and he plays
fight the feeling and he's wondering why
you're not always coming
he's like bro I'm playing fight the
feeling I am excited though cause I'm
seeing that I'm a singing word for word
so they [__] around
like before they are you are you out
no Okay you're from Texas
and it's like that every time